Theresa May met today with impressive
list of senior executives from companies
including Amazon Mars and General
Electric will her charm offensive win
them over
I'm joined from Indianapolis by Aaron
Huntington who is vice president of
international affairs at the us-based
firm Eli Lilly which is one of the
world's biggest pharmaceutical companies
and by John Dickerman who is head of the
CBI in Washington well John let me start
with you you're all you've got your ear
to the ground in Washington what are you
hearing from American business right now
well I think the one thing that we hear
consistently from American businesses
what we hear consistently from British
business which is transparency and
consistency going forward on business
regulations and relationships is very
important right so why don't either do
you think it's going to be for Britain
to cut it bilateral trade deal with the
UK given the I mean mr. Trump seems more
keen on tearing up a lot of the trade
deals that America has got going at
times well I think first and foremost no
trade deal is easy to accomplish but but
secondly what we should be looking at
instead of looking at a specific
bilateral trade deal is probably looking
at areas where we can converge our
economies in the short term for quick
wins quick successes where the US and UK
can actually bolster the already strong
economic relationship that they share
well Irene let me bring you in at this
point
Eli Lilly you employ two and a half
thousand people here in Britain do you
think you'll have more or less than that
in five years time well let me start by
saying Lilly is delighted to be in the
UK we've invested there since the 1930s
and right now we have research and
development facility manufacturing
facility as well so I think our most
important messages we want Britain to be
open for business and open for a very
strong life sciences sector in the
future and are you confident that from
on the basis of what you're hearing
Aaron that will carry on well I think
we've had very good dialogue and
discussion with British stakeholders and
decision makers and we believe that
there's a real willingness to understand
the need for transparency for
cooperation and for good transitional
discussions if this deal moves forward
are you calling for a transition period
then when the UK leaves you do how long
do you think that transition period
should be
I can't speculate on that what I can say
is we want a smooth transition and for
us the most important thing is that
patients can get good access to
medicines and that they don't have any
sort of delay or any kind of challenges
to their care so that's very important
to us as we look forward to the future
so what sort of things would make Lily
invest more in Britain and employ more
people here well what I can say is we
have we have a strong investment now a
couple of things that make the UK a good
place to invest is their openness is the
talent that's there the ability to do
clinical research we want to see those
things continue we want to see a good
environment for innovation so that
patients can get access to medicines and
what do you hear from your peers
elsewhere in the pharmaceutical industry
on that front well I haven't spoken to
all of them directly but I believe
overall as a biopharmaceutical industry
we would agree that we want to see the
UK remain a strong place for investment
and for growth and really again for a
life sciences sector that can bring new
medicines to patients John what do you
think about the current move music
that's coming out of the UK government
we've just heard from our colleague Beth
Rigby there about potential tensions
between Boris Johnson the foreign
secretary in treason may the Prime
Minister is that flickering on the radar
much in the u.s. in the business
community well I think it certainly does
I think it certainly does strike people
you know we hear everything on the news
here but but I don't think it's a
massive concern I think the UK is such
an important investment destination for
the US and vice versa we realize it in
both of our countries we have we have
transitions going on right now that we
need to overcome presumably I mean there
are other factors as well I mean Erin
mentions the transition period just now
but I mean there are fundamental factors
like the the exchange rate and I mean on
that basis the UK's become incredibly
competitive over the last 12 months yeah
there's no question but at the same time
business isn't looking 12 months into
the future they're looking 12 years into
the future so kind of consistency going
beyond the short term is very important
for investment and for investment
decisions
all right Aaron last word to you then if
you had trees are may with you now what
would be the message that you give her I
think the first thing I would say is
don't lose this opportunity for the UK
to really be open for business and to
remain a great place to do clinical
research and to be able to bring
investments as we move forward to the
future all right Aaron Huntington John
Dickerman thanks both thank you